With everything from superhero team-ups to
record-breaking horror releases, 2017 has
been a big year for movies—and an even bigger
year for all the Easter eggs they hid.
It's a lot to go through, so we rounded up
some of the all-time best movie Easter eggs
of 2017.
Some spoilers ahead.
A mop and a beer
The fifth entry in the Pirates of the Caribbean
franchise featured a heavily CGI'd version
of a young Johnny Depp as Captain Jack Sparrow,
but that wasn't the only glimpse into the
actor's past.
Just before Sparrow is set to be executed,
his Uncle Jack--played by ex-Beatle Paul McCartney--tells
him a joke:
"Did I ever tell you the one about the skeleton?"
"Yes you have many time…"
"Skeleton goes into a bar, orders a beer and
a mop."
It sounds like your average bad pirate joke,
but it's actually an Easter egg with roots
20 years in the past that started with Al
Pacino, of all people.
While Depp and Pacino were filming 1997's
Donnie Brasco, Pacino would tell that joke
repeatedly, then laugh and walk off.
Depp later admitted:
"I didn't get the joke!
He thought it was my problem.
He inflicted it upon me and I could feel my
IQ points drop…
He would howl every time he told the joke."
What better way to return the favor than to
inflict it on millions of moviegoers?
Even better, the guy laughing at the joke
in Pirates of the Caribbean sounds a lot like
Pacino.
"Funny as ever."
Play time
Hot on the heels of 2016's Deadpool, Logan
proved once again that it's okay for a superhero
to spill buckets of blood and swear like a
sailor without sacrificing those ever-important
ticket sales.
Hopefully, this will kick off a new trend
in superhero films, but Logan wasn't entirely
focused on the future—it also had a few
pretty sweet callbacks to days of Wolverine
past.
While the comic books Laura picks up play
a big part in the plot, you may not have noticed
another Easter egg that popped up: during
Logan's funeral, you can see one of the mutant
children holding a Wolverine action figure—complete
with yellow spandex.
Considering this is most likely Hugh Jackman's
last outing with the adamantium claws, it
was a nice touch to put Wolverine's early
comics outfit onscreen, even if it only showed
up briefly, and on a plastic toy.
Journey mountain
Director Jordan Vogt-Roberts is a self-proclaimed
video game fanatic, and his sophomore feature
film Kong: Skull Island is jam-packed with
video game nods, with references to everything
from Resident Evil to The Legend of Zelda.
But the best Easter egg in the film doesn't
come from a massive franchise—rather, it's
a subtle nod to Journey, a game in which players
have to cross a huge open world while communicating
with other players via musical notes, all
while trying to reach a glowing mountain in
the distance.
Perhaps to emphasize the journey the characters
in Kong had to take to cross Skull Island,
Vogt-Roberts stuck a re-creation of Journey's
mountain in the distance in a few scenes of
the movie.
It's most visible when the helicopters first
breach the storm around the island, and again
at the end when the characters are leaving.
It's subtle, but awesome once you've spotted
it—a perfect example of what an Easter egg
should be.
Musical cameo
It's the music of Baby Driver that brings
the film to life, which is particularly fitting
considering the core premise has its origins
in a music video.
In 2002, Edgar Wright—who helmed Baby Driver—directed
a music video for "Blue Song" by British band
Mint Royale.
The narrative of the video is this: a sunglasses-wearing
driver takes a group of thieves to a heist,
then waits in the car and lip-syncs to a song.
Sound familiar?
That sequence inspired the opening scene in
Baby Driver, which sees Baby rocking out to
"Bellbottoms" by Jon Spencer Blues Explosion
while the rest of the crew pulls off the heist.
Even better, Wright didn't pay homage to that
video in style only.
During a scene in Baby's apartment, the "Blue
Song" music video can briefly be seen playing
on the TV.
Spider-Signal
You may have missed this quick Easter egg
in Spider-Man Homecoming, because it was only
visible for about a second.
In the scene when Spider-Man is locked in
the warehouse in DC, he starts tinkering with
his suit to pass the time.
"What?"
"Maybe we should run that refresher course."
That's the Spider-Signal, also known as the
worst superhero gadget ever.
The Spider-Signal first appeared in The Amazing
Spider-Man #3, published in 1963, in which
the signal is literally nothing more than
a warning to criminals that Spider-Man is
somewhere nearby.
Usually--surprise!--at the other end of the
beam of light projecting the signal.
So why is this such a great Easter egg compared
to everything else in Homecoming, like the
Ultron head Spidey pulls out of a bag later
in the same scene?
Mainly because it's such a useless detail
to add, and it's all the more amazing because
of that.
Final farewell
The Guardians of the Galaxy movies have a
ton of Easter eggs, but one of the best recurring
eggs in the franchise showed up at Yondu's
funeral.
One of Yondu's favorite trinkets in the first
film was that little blue crystal frog that
he got at the beginning of the movie.
You got any other cute little buggers like
this un?
I like to stick em all in a row on my control
console."
In Guardians 2, just before Yondu is blasted
into space, the camera lingers for a second
on that same frog, sitting by his side just
as it did in life.
Among the hundreds of Easter eggs in Marvel
movies, this is the only one that'll bring
a tear to your eye.
Walt's initials
Spotting secrets in any Disney film is always
fun, and the studio rarely disappoints.
In 2017's live-action Beauty and the Beast,
one of the biggest Easter eggs in the film
is built right into the woodwork, so to speak.
In the Beast's massive, ornate ballroom, pay
attention to the monogram inscribed on the
ballroom floor.
Hidden within the flowery design is a big
"WD"—short for Walt Disney.
Honestly, we'd chalk this one up to a trick
of the eye if this Easter egg hadn't been
confirmed by none other than Sarah Greenwood,
production designer for the film.
Bookwhacked
By every reasonable measure, the Tom Cruise-led
reboot of The Mummy was a complete failure.
Critics bashed the film for everything from
the muddled story to its shameless ripoffs
of previous plots, but there was one little
highlight in the movie that might warrant
a re-watch.
Maybe.
If you hate yourself.
In the scene when Dr. Jekyll goes full-on
Hyde, Annabelle Wallis' character, Jenny,
knocks a guy out by whacking him on the head
with a big book.
Look closely, because that book has made an
onscreen appearance in the past—it's the
Book of the Dead, first seen in 1999's The
Mummy.
You know, the one with Brendan Fraser.
Who would have thought we'd ever miss that
version?
"Ah.."
Gunshot sonata
John Wick: Chapter 2 should be a case study
for sequels done right.
It took everything great about the first film
and made it even better.
A lot of that comes down to the incredible
detail put into building the franchise's hyper-kinetic
world—details that most fans likely won't
even notice.
Probably the best example came at the end
of John Wick 2, during the gun battle in the
museum.
The shootout is set to Vivaldi's Four Seasons,
only the percussion is replaced by the sound
of Wick's gun, literally turning his shots
into the musical score.
It's an insanely obscure Easter egg, but a
fantastic example of an off-kilter detail
that only the filmmakers are likely to ever
notice.
As director Chad Stahelski put it,
"If somebody does pick it up, it'll be two
guys going like, holy s—, that's Vivaldi!"
What's in a name?
We know—Ready Player One isn't getting released
until 2018, but its Easter eggs are already
spilling over into the film's marketing: when
the film's logo was released in July 2017,
fans were quick to spot an Easter egg hiding
right in the name of the film.
If you look closely, the letters in "Ready
Player One" form a maze that runs to a literal
egg in the center of the "O" in "One."
As noted by Gizmodo, that's a nod to Adventure,
a 1979 Atari game that sees the player moving
through the maze-like rooms of a castle.
More importantly, Adventure is widely believed
to contain the first Easter egg in gaming
history, and in the Ready Player One book,
Adventure is a massive inspiration for one
of the characters.
We don't want to give too much else away,
so you'll have to read the book or wait until
March 2018 to see how all those pieces connect.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!